Miren este dibujo.
¿Saben qué es?
Soy bioquímica molecular de formación,
y he visto muchos de estos dibujos.
Por lo general se los conoce como figuras modelo;
un dibujo que muestra cómo pensamos
que ocurre un proceso molecular o celular.
Este dibujo particular es de un proceso
llamado endocitosis mediada por clatrina.
Ahí una molécula puede pasar
del exterior de una célula, al interior.
La molécula es capturada en una burbuja o una vesícula,
que luego es internalizada por la célula.
No obstante, este dibujo tiene un problema
y es principalmente lo que no muestra.
A partir de muchos experimentos
de muchos científicos diferentes,
sabemos bastante sobre el aspecto de estas moléculas
y cómo se mueven por la célula.
Todo esto ocurre
en un entorno increíblemente dinámico.
Por eso, en colaboración con Tomas Kirchhausen, un experto en clatrina,
decidimos crear un nuevo tipo de figura modelo
que mostrara todo eso.
Empezamos fuera de la célula.
Ahora estamos mirando adentro.
La clatrina son esas moléculas de 3 patas
que pueden autoensamblarse en forma de pelotas de fútbol.
Por conexiones con una membrana,
la clatrina puede deformar la membrana
y crear esta especie de taza
que forma esta especie de burbuja, o vesícula,
que ahora captura unas proteínas
inicialmente fuera de la célula.
Las proteínas ingresan ahora que básicamente pellizcan esta vesícula,
separándola del resto de la membrana.
Ya la clatrina prácticamente hizo su trabajo,
y ahora ingresan las proteínas
—las cubrimos de amarillo y naranja—
responsables de quitar esta jaula de clatrina.
Estas proteínas pueden reciclarse
y usarse otra vez.
Estos procesos son muy pequeños como para verse directamente,
incluso con los mejores microscopios.
Animaciones como estas son una forma poderosa
de visualizar una hipótesis.
Esta es otra ilustración;
un dibujo de cómo podría pensarse
que el virus VIH entra y sale de las células.
De nuevo, una simplificación excesiva
que muestra una parte ínfima
de lo que sabemos sobre estos procesos.
Quizá les sorprenda saber
que estos simples dibujos son la única forma
como la mayoría de los biólogos visualizan sus hipótesis moleculares.
¿Por qué?
Porque crear videos de procesos que muestren
lo que pensamos que ocurre, es muy difícil.
Pasé meses en Hollywood aprendiendo a usar software de animación 3D,
y estuve meses con cada animación.
Muchos investigadores no disponen de ese tiempo.
Sin embargo, los beneficios pueden ser enormes.
Las animaciones moleculares son incomparables
por su capacidad para transmitir gran cantidad de información
a amplias audiencias con una precisión extrema.
Y ahora trabajo en un nuevo proyecto
titulado "La ciencia del VIH"
en el que estaré animando todo el ciclo de vida
del virus VIH con la mayor precisión posible
y todo en detalle molecular.
La animación contará con datos
recolectados durante décadas, de miles de investigadores;
datos del aspecto del virus,
de cómo puede infectar a las células del cuerpo,
y de cómo los agentes terapéuticos ayudan a combatir la infección.
Con los años, encontré que las animaciones
no son solo útiles para comunicar una idea,
sino que también sirven
para explorar una hipótesis.
Los biólogos, en su mayor parte, siguen usando papel y lápiz
para visualizar los procesos que estudian.
Con los datos que tenemos hoy, eso ya no es suficientemente bueno.
Crear una animación
puede ser un catalizador que le permita a los investigadores
cristalizar y refinar sus propias ideas.
Trabajé con otra investigadora que
estudia mecanismos moleculares
de enfermedades neurodegenerativas.
Ella propuso experimentos relacionados
directamente con la animación en la que trabajamos juntas.
De esa forma la animación puede retroalimentar la investigación.
Creo que la animación puede cambiar la biología.
Puede cambiar la forma de comunicarnos,
la forma de explorar nuestros datos
y la forma de enseñar.
Pero para que ocurra esto,
necesitamos que más investigadores creen animaciones.
Para eso reuní a un equipo
de biólogos, animadores y programadores
para crear un software nuevo, gratuito y de código abierto
al que llamamos "Molecular Flipbook",
creado por biólogos
para hacer animaciones moleculares.
En nuestras pruebas encontramos que en solo 15 minutos
un biólogo, que no había usado nunca software de animación,
crea su primera animación molecular
de su propia hipótesis.
Estamos creando una base de datos en línea
en la que todos puedan ver, descargar y contribuir
con sus propias animaciones.
Estamos muy emocionados de anunciar que
la versión beta del software de animación molecular
estará disponible para descargar hoy.
Será inteesante ver lo que los biólogos van a crear
y las nuevas ideas que podrán descubrir
al poder animar finalmente
sus propias figuras modelo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)